hey yes I want to talk about SVG reality
and I might be a famous sculptor but
I'll make it entertaining so I want to
talk about this problem and some of you
orbit over like myself would remember
that the web needs to be 1024 and
everyone was just doing 1024 big
question was do you do 60 pixels wide
I'm evening maybe a thousand if you're
like 960 there you go just like so but
sort of things have changed a lot we've
gone from desktop computers with CRT
monitors it's all up with the same
number pixels to what is going on with
these fixes devices have caught totally
crazy we've got every synchro leaf
resolution imagine not only that pixels
have now gone crazy and have more
pictures in them however that works so I
think I think I think we've better
excuse better languages and I think what
we really have have to work with is
something that fits these new
technologies we need to software
languages that fit the hardware that we
create we need something I can adapt
another thing that we've come up with
like I said it's high DPI so that means
we've got more than one device pixel for
CSS pixel or pro logical fix and
suddenly all of our assets that are
meant to look beautiful and I resolution
suddenly look not so high resolution
anymore you know they're the same assets
somehow people have sort of gotten used
to expecting super crisp text and if you
have some good sex why you picked your
column at sharp sure you can just beam
massive assets down I is
group allemagne that you're going to use
or or falls to do but it's not very
sustainable and it's not really
necessary for a lot of use cases I think
it's better than the format that
stretches and when you think of that we
have had these formats for a long long
time we've you know we've thankfully got
rid of flash which was kind of like that
but not really the best tool to God for
a wreath we've had things like SVG for
what a lot now CSS also has a lot of
ways to do that see there's a lot of it
has a lot of ways and here's here's one
cycle one good leg off you're a lot of
genomic which turns a single live into
any icon using a variety because hacks
using 2d elements and a lot of order
order drinks background tricks gradients
all over the place but I think that's
pretty much thing I don't think we just
go like that I think it's really cool to
be clever enough to come up with those
things but we should not be using that
it's not good software engineering I
feel like we're kind of those we're by
doing roof / CSS if you're familiar with
that it's the concept of having an
extremely fragile machine that does
something really intricate it's
completely unmaintained a bowl put it
looks pretty sweet it's very
entertaining it makes jewelry smart when
you like put it all together but it's
crazy right so instead of that what do
you something like as fini scalable
vector graphics that are pretty much
designed to solve this problem and have
done so for a decade now for more but we
haven't really been using them pretty
well at least I am so I want to share a
little bit of what I've discovered and
another look at them in the last year or
so adding a sticky as a it's one to one
standard that's extremely huge and
everyone sort of underestimates it I
think you can do a lot of things that
people
expect and I think going forward with
sort of where the future from the
development is heading you think of what
components anything goes in your icons
route 60 the modularization other
applications are going on your bill
think of the few thing you know the
current awesome stuff that we have in
css3 and versus a subtle for others
wherever all that's going I think SVG is
ideally placed to take advantage of all
of that and become a core part of our
application architecture so we're going
to be quoting SVG just like we are
putting CSS today which is something up
give me 10 years ago we wouldn't have
thought that was more time to do because
we were doing everything indication on
JavaScript and then serve javis can win
and became totally crazy huge awesome
but it's actually very simple language
compared to something like a CG which
supports a lot lot more it's kind of
like html5 together with the big swap I
suspect your schoolwork was really small
SPG something something like that except
even more and I don't think we can cover
a nearly the entire standard today but I
want to just introduce you and tell you
guys that that this is an amazing
technology that's available a lot of
browsers and you think think about it
it's not my intention to talk too much
about the browser support because I
think almost everything to look at it's
going to be broken in some browsers and
that's kind of flying in a world right
here because we focus on the future the
but the lessons we learned here from all
the amazing speakers today are things
that are going to matter to us for years
to come so I don't want to focus on
legacy support I think most of the stuff
that even isn't working right now
rogersville options for it either
already available or coming out soon to
sort of let us play with it and see
where this is all head so I want to get
away from this which to me is how I sort
of wanted to present that Nia that this
Tiger is SVG as it was 10 or more years
ago I've seen this
picture again and again again and I want
to get away from this pointless use of
SVG and to something like help us build
applications and be cool like the
colonist so Who am I my name is
Sebastian I'm front-end developer i live
in florida queer kind of comfortable
co-founders a lot of startups and I'm
just basically good friend following all
the time we're not a number of projects
on board with all that so without
further ado let us talk about some of
the community stuff that we have here as
well someone actually probably this
figure to take a lot of mess of people
here president right now this was a few
days ago there's a bit really vibrant
community of front of developers in
Singapore and I just wanted a sort of
share that I think it's amazing the way
that developers have sort of gotten
together in Singapore across all hot for
all languages there's as you can see
with the fs there's something to be a
point here every single day there's
something for everyone really it's just
every single year I've been here for
years every single you're pretty much
doubles in science I think it's
wonderful and I look forward to all
future guess cops and super so if we can
look at scg coming from you know red CSS
com we're all trying to develop it
almost it was a primary developers it's
actually very similar in what we used to
so I don't think you can see that so
basically it supports you know like
device independent pixels animations
hardware acceleration you know very
proud to support but some amazing
performance is possible blending modes
are really interesting there in my hat
you might have used some lightning ones
at CSS but they're kind of there it's
basically what lets us do photoshop kind
of effects with layers between HTML
elements or SVG elements you know you
can make it responsive you can use your
luck inspector
where there are tools to deploy the
things it's very very easy to do you've
got no filters it has a dog maybe I just
like you're really stew with the HTML so
it makes it very powerful to build on
top of it using logic to create elements
to drive changes there's a lot of
libraries that basically built on top of
that make it very easy it's got
scripting you'd embed it so not only can
you access doing your SVG structures
with scripts with external scripts and
manipulate the Dom the SPG's can
actually that's between elements or
documents also contain Java can also
contain embed JavaScript just like an
HTML page or an HTML document would that
has certain security implications for
example would you allow javascript to
run an SVG icon on your desktop no of
course not it's there's certain places
where you can run it certain places
where you cannot as things like color
profiles which you notes there's it's
sort of a nice feature but like for
people to print it's really important on
the web it's sort of are probably going
to become more important once we get to
things like high dynamic range displays
in the coming years now how do you use
SVG's well I think a lot of you have
probably seen some of the common usage
patterns just you know replacing a ping
file with a good an SPG things like that
so let me run through some of the main
and is it visit not all of them there's
actually an incredible variety of ways
to use SVG so I'm going to run through
some of the main ones one of my favorite
ones is the html5 you know native
support for the SVG element you don't
have to do anything for it just open an
element SVG and you can drop any kind of
SVG elements within that any kind of
shapes I can get really complicated of
course but do simple things with that in
your daily development if you need to
draw a line between something you don't
have through hacks with Porter borders
and all that kind of stuff you can just
draw a line and that's big deal it takes
very little code to do that you no
longer have to worry about
namespaces and all these kind of things
and you know it renders beautifully it's
high performance it's cleaner code you
can read the code and it means that
there's an actual line there is no
longer like somehow a div with a border
bottom somewhere else define in CSS file
it's very clean it works really well in
large-scale applications and I've really
been using that a lot lately so another
way to do it that probably more people
are familiar with right now is uh just
loading in a URL function in CSS and
these can be used in a lot of places
like background images obviously this
style in which is those little those
little glyphs in front of the you know I
could've ordered lists out of us for an
unordered list things like the border
image that's a something that you can do
some neat tricks with it's not the most
high-performance most browsers but it
works Purser's sort of flaky support
right now but again not really concerned
with that and content you know like for
your sooo elements like your before and
after you can draw images within them
which is kind of it SVG fonts probably
most of you have heard of them or seen
them whenever you copy paste that you
know that some custom font from like
font awesome or whatever service that
you use as many fonts are sort of
deprecated but it looks like and this is
just looking on mailing lists and
discussions there's a lot of interest in
multicolor fonts I thought it was a bit
weird at first which I which we call the
court once but then you know emoji
everybody loves sending emoji emoticons
and those have readings those have
shadows there's a lot of colors and
there's competing standards right now so
SVG's possibly making a comeback in
fonts there's a lot of support in next
15 spot elements dedicated to you know
fonts and like structuring upon in SVG
and most of those are right now sort of
like brushed aside but they might come
back and
when they do we'll have things like
colorful fonts we'll have the fonts
gradients within a single glyphs will
have shadows without you know it will be
beautiful scalable moved the world will
be possible so that's sort of something
that right now I you know probably
shouldn't be using but in a couple of
years who knows another way to use them
right now which is it's actually really
cool it's a better way to do sprites so
if you're doing if you're combining a
lot of small images into a larger image
then you know it you have to set up
another book build stab all these kind
of stuff and you have to deal with
change in core minutes and stuff and
things like that it gets a little bit
unwieldy sometimes it's it's a really
really nice way to do it is to just
stack all of them in a single SVG and
you can also you can again use a bill a
bill stepp for that but it but i'm
really used to actually manage that
within your your your SVG editors like
illustrator or inkscape and the way to
reference them is by just using a URL
like like like these two here the first
one is how you actually reference SVG
fragments inside your SVG files so if
you're embedding in line SPG in your
document you can use the use element
with a this x-linked hrh reference it's
not the produce language words you can
reference your file and then do a
fragment identifier in the URL and that
will pull up the ID like the element
with the ID that you specify like
in this case it will pull up the fox
element and render only that it won't
render anything else so you can have 100
icons in there and it will just pick up
that single that's single I element it's
a really nice way to do sort of icon
sheets for icon stacks or whatever II
call them it also works and image source
in your regular HTML so in this case i
would pick the same file but pick a
different element and i would not see
the box and
rather than the other one I think it
also works in the background image sorry
I didn't check that right now so let's
let's have a quick look em I'm sure you
know probably some of you have already
seen you know what SVG looks like what I
can do with it the basic level so i'll
just quickly skip through this so the
basic building blocks of ice cream are
really you know i could CSS you have
your units they're actually exactly the
same in fact SVG specification says you
know our units are basically the same
ones as define its users 2.1 the old
stuff so but it hasn't really changed
that much good three anyway and i'm
talking about cious SVG 1.1 which is
pretty old but it's it's sort of what
everyone uses today the basic shapes are
sort of simple ways to define common
geometric shapes so if you want to do a
rectangle you can make it any size you
want you can give a round of it like a
little bordering this sort of thing it's
not as powerful as like for example
aboard reuse its CSS where you can do
crazy things with like order reporters
that sort of have different slopes on
the vertical horizontal ones on every
corner to be different it's very limited
in an SVG but most of the times you just
want to do a simple shape in any way you
can do that the complex ones you can
also do but it requires a little bit
more manual work usually you want to do
that with the X icon like a visitor
anyway so there's other shapes of
ellipses and circles new lines and
polylines are like that little that
little lightning you can just put
coordinates it's pretty easy to do this
manually you don't need an editor it's
you know it's relatively straightforward
I won't go through all the syntax you
can just look it up in a reference
polygons etc the last one is more like a
like a path actually so Pat's it's not
that important right now but the past
you can do things like lines arcs busier
curves however you pronounce that
quadratic curves basically in cute
little geometric shapes they are vain
to do manually I'll tell you so it uses
a weird text based drawing instructions
thing where your move to a point and you
draw at another point and you have
control points and it's impossible to do
these things in your head so basically
copy paste from like sketch illustrator
an excuse for them so that's that's the
basic fundamental of drawing shapes and
stuff if you wanna reference bitmap
images or other SVG's there's an image
element which is not IMG but it which
the forward again with that X link href
and you know it supports any file format
that that your your browser would
otherwise render we've also base64
encode them in a URL so this is again
stuff that were all used to and it makes
it very very convenient to nest other
images in your image and reference them
we use them leverage at all caching that
we have with HTTP it's a nice way to
basically have documents that reference
outer document which is something that
you can't really do with any other image
format like like paint or JPEG it's a it
can be a really powerful feature man
when used appropriately there's a lot of
other stuff which you know I don't have
nearly enough time to cover right now
you could probably do entire hour long
talk about each of these things it's
there they're amazingly powerful you
know you can move all kinda velopment
and treat them as long and into
transformations on top of them it's
really cool patterns again
transformations right we're not going to
get into all of that so let's just go
ahead the SPG gone okay it's something
where I'm really excited because we're
at CSS conflict but there's also GS com
tomorrow and the DOM is really how you
make things interactive in HTML and
almost the exact same methods apply to
SVG so if you're building an application
in HTML you might as well just do it in
SVG and say you know we've got all these
beautiful shapes and lines and
connecting things a lot of times you're
doing data visualization don't bother
with HTML and trying to mock things up
with fake elements all over the place
and containers
right just do this video straight away
javascript makes it really easy to deal
with you do have to worry about
namespaces because XML you know too
biased against XML I think it's actually
not too big of a deal one you can easily
work around it right a couple of helper
functions that deal with this because
basically it's the same code so you
create element set attribute get element
except you have to specify a namespace
which is just a little string day at
this net supply it it can sometimes make
it a little bit tricky like you know
what why is this element not showing up
it's because my browser doesn't
recognize it it thinks it's nation LOL
and after you should be SVG element it
gets a little bit weird sometimes but
just keep it in mind to help you with
that stuff you can also use a number of
libraries here are some of the common
ones there's a there's a queue that's a
green sock is really cool I've been
using it for some pretty heavy front-end
animated animated stuff there I'm deal
with campuses that are hundreds of
thousands of pixels squared and the
performance of this stuff is amazing you
want to use your probably want to use
one of these rappers because things like
transformations in SVG are a pain when
you when you when you're coming from CSS
simply because the things like things
like the the transform origin are a
little bit different they're not in the
senator in a corner and it just can get
really confusing and these these use API
is a sort of like pave over all of that
consistency as well as help you with
some of the the shortcomings that
browsers still have today so you know I
able to have a look at these as Rafael
there's synaptics Fiji there's SVG SMG
sap the green some animation so like I
said earlier you know the doucher of the
web's is probably going to be web
components right but I don't know how
many of you have already been playing
with this I I find amazing
that these things are now in the browser
and if you look at things like Oliver if
you look at X tag they just work it's
amazing you don't really get a lot more
flexibility in how you structure your
application which I'll just to reuse a
lot more code which allows us to build
more advanced software in less time or
at same time and what your point can now
do is create your own elements in HTML
you can do the same thing in SVG and the
way it works is not really right now
we're working with things like polymer
but if you if you do if you coat it with
a standard epi yourself this actually
works in the browser test this out and
then you can extend the behavior of
elements basically making your view just
an element that you can invoke anywhere
you want any application so for example
what I'm creating here wouldn't register
his helmet here I could then instantiate
that I could assign I could I could I
could attach custom behavior to it you
would inherit from in this case SVG
circle I could make that an interactive
circle I could attach automatically
eject all the event handlers that
monitor touch input eielson foot and you
know it sort of lets you neatly wrap a
lot of your functionality so again this
is not about web components but I think
that it's amazing that we can do this
across HTML as well as SVG and again
shows the the power that s what she has
in joining our stack as front of
developers and roller so not just HTML
works for this routine we can also do
the same with CSS it's it's what you use
to basically give a markup and there's
there's a lot of different ways to do
that with CSS in SVG so here's some of
the common ones there's a lot of other
ways as well but sort of the the main
ways of doing it especially when you're
doing in line SVG in your document which
is why it's so preferred is to actually
have your CSS referenced like you would
normally have it in your HTML page in
HTML document
and it can actually set selectors here
your CSS that target things inside the
SVG document because it's embedded it
becomes you know very straightforward
for everyone I'm team to understand
could become you use the same
modularization approach that you that
you would for the other of using
application and now applies to SVG
elements it's very seamless in councils
good you know things like inline CSS on
your SVG elements directly but again
just like we don't do that with a
squeegee these people hope we don't do
that those are good HTML and you again
probably shouldn't be doing a whole lot
of CSS in line and it's between you just
like we would be nice to know there's a
as you might see here there's a there's
some new property using SVG what's
different properties in SVG there's also
certain properties that don't really
work I'm not going to go through an
entire list there's plenty of resources
available online basically whenever you
draw a line or a shape you use things
like stroke you settle with on that
scope you can fill that shape these are
very straightforward concepts you can
move things for like more advanced with
patterns that you just slug the whole
thing we deliver the texture with some
kind of utter utter designs these are
things that aren't really there and CSS
they make they make a lot more a lot of
designs with it something become
possible and that like easy that would
otherwise be really hard to pull off and
playing CSS and HTML so yeah there's
other ways like I can pull in external
track style sheets directly into your
ass with you which is kind of convenient
when you have a standalone SVG file what
you can do is use at the xml style sheet
instruction to actually load a CEO that
smile it's slightly different from what
you would what you would do with a link
tag in HTML but it works just the same
again allows you to separate all your
design from your instructor allows you
to leverage caching again as well so all
benefits that were used to exist in SVG
and I'll run through every couple of a
couple of things that i came across and
we're surprising to me in my experience
using SVG in my web applications there's
there's things that are really strange
at first for example the view box this
is one this is one of those things that
you sort of have to you know you have
the crockett before SVG starts to make
sense before you can actually think SVG
the few bucks is an attribute on the SVG
element where you did turn that great
you can specify which part of the you
know that sort of SVG canvas will show
up when you embed that SVG in your
content it's it's kind of interesting to
think about that you could actually do a
crop and a transform essentially if you
look at the screenshot the measuring the
groove the rulers their show the entire
document that squeegee document
basically all the campus as well as
locally and the orange box is what gets
shown where this SVG will be embedded so
the like for example the eyes and most
of the beak of this bird would not
appear when this which is embedded but
you can easily change which part gets
shown the other thing about the view box
is that you can stretch and scale
without having to touch all the
coordinates in your your geometric
shapes in this case if you look at the
view box attribute by the way its case
sensitive it's kind of painful because
jquery doesn't really like that very
much a lot about our tools also have
issues with that with case sensitive
attributes but so you have 100 100 200
150 now 100 100 is your translation
which means that if you have enough like
if you have a use case where you want to
pan across an SVG an image you can use
those first two values
to move the view box over your image
without touching any of the image
elements and all any of the children's
coordinates is one of those things where
I feel like that didn't really belong a
few bucks but they put it there anyway
and it's there now and you know you
usually just leave them at zero zero and
to deal with the view box that starts at
the origin point where it belongs
essentially the 200 150 obviously is a
the size of the view box but the tricky
bit about that is that size is sort of
it's a little it's a little bit more
complicated but basically there's no
units on it and what that means is that
you can specify you know you're not the
work because it's a pixel is this a.m is
this a point is it up pick up you can
use you don't have to worry about limits
they're all called user units
essentially in the user coordinate
system and all kind of stuff they get
scaled to whatever you set as the width
or height now the width or height are
optional so what that means is you can
create your L your your SVG content
independent of where it's going to show
how large it's going to be but you can
still use the simplicity of calculating
as sort of a virtual pixels so you can
specify content that's you know 175 and
25 and just you just look at a 200 as
your total size and that will scale
perfectly wherever that's being used
wherever that's which you will end up
being embedded and as you change the
size of the width and the height for
example if I were to change that to
percents one hundred percent with it
would scale perfectly is very easy to
make responsive and it scales perfectly
something really hard to do with HTML
you know I imagine if you had to scale
an HTML element and all the children
automatically you just I think later on
in the day there'll be some talks about
that but uh things like flexbox but uh
but that's what G it's extremely easy to
do this so one issue with that it's what
happens when you scale them but the
aspect ratio is different from that of
the few bucks
you get sort of a funhouse mirror effect
that's what i was going for you
essentially there's there's another
attribute SVG called preserve aspect
ratio may nicknames it's it's got a ring
weird syntax but i don't haven't seen
any uh it's similar to that and CSS but
it sort of works like your background
size property in CSS not as powerful but
can be used to do similar things where
background size can do you know
stretching a background image to contain
or to cover and it will crop the image
or a little letter box the the
background image basically in element
it's sort of the same way where if you
if you embed an SVG element inside let's
say an HTML block and your HTML blocks
fetches really wide you can then use
preserve aspect ratio to detect to
determine how it gets stretched or if
it's squeezed or what happens to it
there's a you know there's a little
image here just include as you can find
us online it's a really you know it's
one of those things once you get it it
just makes sense and it's one of those
things well when you're dealing with
responsive SVG i always reference this
move is the this horrible image because
just explains it every single time
things like cover and contain become an
SPG become meet slice things like
aligning to a good background position
where you stick stick elements to the
left to the right to the top to the
bottom or in the center is somehow x is
lower case and why is uppercase I don't
know is it it just makes it up it
doesn't make a lot of sense and it also
doesn't have you to do things like you
come like you're used to in CSS where to
go to do it to one side and offset it by
a certain percentage or a number of
pixels you can do slightly thing
slightly more powerful things in CSS but
this sort of works
in a lot of cases and gets job that he
owes work around us the problems anyway
one more thing that you should probably
aware of it unlike HTML you know the
limit to how big your skin your SVG can
rent on the screen so in HTML with CSS
you can you can have you can set up you
know an image that has a million billion
pixels you know squared or whatever in
that minutes and it's fine the browser
doesn't really care too much about that
I'll is still thing and life goes on
with SVG you know of SPG things crash
that's do you can crash iOS things run
out of texture every on on the GPU the
drivers are buggy for those those kind
of things and you end up in a really bad
situation really quickly it's sort of
similar to what happens when you have
extremely large JPEGs and files other
app images the what happens is that they
don't get tiled as much as they get
rendered into a texture the tribute to
make things faster the whole thing gets
rasterized uploaded into the GPU and
then things have yeah get limited very
quickly what you need to do really is i
think use that what I've done anyway is
use that view box trick where you do a
transform you basically restrain the
size of the view box and use transform
to sort of pan around if you really want
to show it at exhuming you can connect
it to a a little bit of JavaScript
you're connected to your scrolling in
your panning and as you're as you're
moving around just update the view box
and things render things update really
quickly lotus which you could sell
harder x over it anyway you get like
let's say here you get infinite
resolution which basically means using
that same view box trick you could
specify a beaut review bucks that's
unreeling pixels wide and it could scale
down to how to fixify without the pixels
or something you get extreme precision
but it doesn't really make a difference
in terms of the limit on how many fixes
you can render to that's basically
limited by the operating system by your
graphics drivers and berries from device
to device
varies from browser to browser it's a
big picking a little tricky I recommend
keeping it under 5 megapixels and that
means if you have one pixel height you
can do 5 55 million pixels wide keep it
something like the size of this the size
of the screen is typically are good idea
don't go beyond that so if you don't
know me on like a 4k I left that way i
wanted to mention a couple of small
things about optimizing it's a Fugees
because they're written like you write
HTML yeah things like comments because
of the way tools output SPG's when
you're editing them it might turn out if
you very very verbose code or XML and
there's there's a tool called s you go
let's video I pronounce that it's got
easy way to integrate it with your grunt
and your gulp stack and it's sort of you
know compresses it a little bit most of
the compression are you getting it on
svgs is going to be from gzip over HTTP
its is still going to be plain text
right but it sort of makes it a little
bit better you'd be surprised how how
bad some of the tools are at outputting
really really verbose for comments that
are totally useless things like paths it
will string them together into a single
path instead of having like many
sections as your designer is drawing
them so let's jump too much is really
nice to use with that it's all automated
of course and you know that I think that
about covers it but there's a couple of
more things I wanted to hear animation I
haven't really touched on now with
animation you can do it in a variety of
ways so obviously you can use CSS
animations if you've already covered CSS
SPG certain properties cannot be
animated right now whereas it could be
in HTML so instead it might make more
sense to use JavaScript something like
those those those are the wrappers of
the API rappers that I mentioned earlier
things like jisa I've been using it it's
really high performance it makes it very
easy into code
exactly the same as you're used to in
HTML you can bend you can also use smell
or sm IL it's actually recommended way
of moving animations in in SVG it looks
really nice when you quoted it's
basically just another attack is the
anime to tag I'm not going to go into
detail here again it's a whole top of a
topic of its own but it gets really good
performance it's the way forward and
speaking of the way forward we're going
to have SVG to presume that shows that
there's a similar to that show that
there's a lot of promise a lot of
investment happening in to SVG because I
think people recognize that it is part
of the future of front-end development
there was an effort all.svg 1.2 there
was a whole bunch of stuff going on
around us we'd be tiny for mobile
devices you know it turns out that
mobile devices are as powerful as that's
no more powerful than Meyer grab your
laptop there and that whole effort sort
of God you know rebooted and it's
alcohol des v-22 and it's going to have
you know some improvements over SVG 1.1
which is like I said the current one
current version but it's it's I think
it's more about getting all these
companies that are building our tools
that are all of us who are using it
getting all these people organizing
their community again to improve the
standards that work with on a day-to-day
basis and I think that's really exciting
and I look forward to using more
standards like SVG in our bucket
applications to make better products for
our users and I think with that thank
you thank you SAP QA and we have one
question hello do you suggest replacing
all images on the web site with SVG or
do you have certain ways to figure out
which images to changes to the estrogen
good question good question so there's
going to be images
that are you know more suited to JPEG
compression compression very high
velocity compression right things like
things that you would do with Bing files
a lot of times work better with a
squeegee simply because you're using
pain actually for with with lossless
compression when especially when there's
a lot of geometric shapes and that works
perfectly with SVG and in fact most of
the times the tools that the designers
use to create those images are in fact
vector editors so you might as well
output that straight away especially
once you go looking at everything has to
be read in assets for mobile devices
things like that it makes a lot of sense
to turn pretty much everything files
into an SVG JPEGs not really but you
could still use them to do so like
reference them from an SVG element just
to get access to things like filters
transformations again but filters you
can do blending modes which basically
means that you could dive a little bit
deeper into the stack of how your images
are composited and if you can take your
smaller you know la la si compressed
files and composite them using blending
modes you might save a lot of space as
well I might be able to do a lot more
cool effects with those images using SVG
again all right more questions hello um
so when you use normal pictures they all
indexed by Google so what degree are
Google indexing SVG even I'm just I
think you'd have to ask google that I'm
not sugar haven't gotten tests on to SU
I'm sorry I can sure thanks in theory
though it shouldn't be impossible at all
it's basically the same it's just
another document but they could parse
very easily it might actually be a lot
easier than doing single day jobs which
you know we're all doing
do you suggest the fallback solution too
just in case process doesn't support SVG
so load in PNG or whatever so if you're
using something like Raphael they go all
crazy and they've sort of replicate SVG
using is a single vml for Microsoft
which is like years old you could do all
that there's also cases where you're
using just SVG as a rendering back-end
like for example with vgs but if you're
building applications it's really hard
to do that so you have to consider your
audience and decide whether SVG is a
appropriate solution today even if it
isn't I think it makes sense to look at
it because in a couple of years everyone
will actually have support and I think
even if you look at can you accommodate
xfinty has amazing support and most most
browsers and devices I've been
struggling with working with the SVG Dom
getting assets for the SVG DOM and
manipulating them in JavaScript do you
have any kind of workflow that you've
used before to get those assets
optimized and just for work with SVG
dumb how would you load it just in high
level general do you mean I spent your
assets what happens its assets that you
can just load up into SVG Dom inside
your document and then manipulate
manipulating JavaScript like reading sog
based applications okay so for example
if you're using tools like sketch
illustrator day like sport like the SPG
pads if you if you consider that asset
right so when you're doing it when you
do animations you can also do animations
along a path for example you typically
keep those in separate files and I like
to have build tools that again I've
category inject them according to IDs
and n reference them by ID which
typically I mapped to a file name but
these are just these are just my
personal conventions it's an interesting
question I'm sure as more people use
them use SVG I think more of these
patterns will become
sort of commonplace I think right now
it's a very flexible very fluid kind of
scenario so everyone's just testing it
out happy to talk more about it as I get
more experience with it myself hi just
ask another question about html5 canvas
so these are most motor thing to talk
about SVG's kind of can be done in
ischemic campus and to me right the HTML
canvas renders less elements in just one
dumb animal fly itself so in SVG
actually kind of create a lot elements
especially when you do some current
interactions you add my admin side so
the I think the dogs had two renders a
lot so what do you think what that s the
converse is self can be Brenda as a as
an image so to me is rather Easter on a
light so what do you think about that
was relevant a lot I think when you look
at SVG there's you can look at it as
there's content there sometimes you look
like a lot of data in your recipe and
it's nice to be able to like to be able
to index it away or reviews that are
tools to access that data whereas if you
render it all into a bitmap I'm really
hard to do that it's also the all the
geometric shapes the paths those are
such as drawing instructions which you
know if you're gonna draw into canvas
you still need a passive instructions
you need JavaScript doing it again with
SVG they become a little bit more
normalized sort of other tools can help
optimize them and simplify those
instructions I don't think that canvas
has that much of help advantage of
performance again in various relative
rouser but I think the number of
elements by itself is not really
metric for performance is I think having
more office actually helps us develop
because it gives you better insight into
how is this constructive how is this
module constructed again things like be
able to create your own custom elements
of the few cat but I think that's
something that it would be really hard
to see how and this for example so I
it's really difficult to imagine
reusable modular interoperable weights
to create components for canvas just as
we could do with HT minus eg hope that
addresses salute